SIGNIFICANTLY OUTGUNNED IN THE
AIR.
UKRAINIAN PILOTS ARE MORE THAN
ANSWERING THE CALL.
>> Reporter: COUNTED OUT EARLY
IN THE WAR BUT STILL GOING
STRONG.
AGAINST ALL THE ODDS, RUSSIA HAS
NOT MANAGED TO GROUND UKRAINE'S
AIR FORCE.
WE SPOKE TO FIGHTER PILOT
ANDREI, WHO WAS IN AN
UNDISCLOSED LOCATION AND HIDING
HIS IDENTITY FOR SAFETY
LOCATIONS.
>> Translator: AT FIRST, RUSSIAN
PILOTS DOMINATED IN QUANTITY OF
FIGHTERS AND EQUIPMENT.
NOW THEY'RE STARTING TO REFUSE
TO FLY BECAUSE WE'RE SHOOTING
THEM.
>> Reporter: HE FLIES AN SU-27
AIR SUPERIORITY FIGHTER.
THIS IS VIDEO PROVIDED BY THE
UKRAINIAN MILITARY OF THE SAME
MODEL, AN OLDER PLANE, BUT ONE
THAT'S STILL EFFECTIVE.
>> Translator: I SHOT DOWN
RUSSIAN CLAIMS.
UNFORTUNATELY I CANNOT SAY WHICH
AND HOW MANY AND HOW EXACTLY I
SHOT THEM DOWN.
AIR MISSILES, GROUND-TO-AIR
MISSILES WERE REPEATEDLY FIRED
AT ME.
THERE WAS A FLIGHT WHEN WE FLEW
THREE AGAINST 24.
IT MEANS OUR THREE FIGHTERS
REPELLED THE ATTACK OF THEIR 24
AIRCRAFT.
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE FOR US TO VERIFY
THOSE CLAIMS, BUT DURING OUR
INTERVIEW, WE HEARD WHAT SEEMED
TO BE A UKRAINIAN JET TAKING
OFF.
ANDRY SAYS THE U.S. HELPED TEACH
HIM AND HIS FELLOW AIRMEN HOW TO
BEAT THE RUSSIANS.
>> Translator: WE HAD OUR
TACTICS.
WE CONDUCTED THE CLEAR SKY
EXERCISE WITH OUR AMERICAN
FRIENDS.
WE ARE NOW USING SOME OF THE
TACTICS WE LEARNED FROM THE
AMERICANS.
>> Reporter: THE U.S. AND ITS
ALLIES INITIALLY BELIEVED RUSSIA
WOULD OWN THE SKIES OVER UKRAINE
JUST DAYS AFTER THEIR INVASION.
BUT THE SPOKESMAN FOR UKRAINE'S
AIR FORCE SAYS THEY WERE READY.
>> Translator: WE'VE BEEN
PREPARING FOR THIS SCENARIO FOR
EIGHT YEARS.
IT CANNOT BE SAID THAT OUR
MILITARY DID NOT THINK THIS
WOULD HAPPEN.
WE'VE DESTROYED 100 AIRCRAFT AND
123 HELICOPTERS ALREADY.
>> Reporter: A LOT OF RUSSIAN
AIRCRAFT HAVE BEEN TAKEN DOWN BY
SHOULDER-LAUNCHED MISSILES
SUPPLIED BY WESTERN ALLIES.
BUT THE UKRAINIANS STILL
SEPARATE LONGER RANGE SYSTEMS
LIKE THE S-300.
THE AIR FORCE SPOKESMAN SAYS
UKRAINE WANTS WESTERN MISSILES
AND U.S. JETS.
>> Translator: I'M TALKING ABOUT
NATO INTEGRATED AIR DEFENSE
SYSTEMS AND F-15 EAGLE, F-16
FIGHTING FALCON.
THEY MAY BE UNUSED OR
DECOMMISSIONED ONES, BUT THEY
COULD SERVE THE UKRAINIAN
MILITARY.
>> Reporter: FOR ANDRY, THE
BATTLE FOR THE SKIES OVER
UKRAINE IS PERSONAL.
BOTH HIS MOTHER AND HIS WIFE ARE
HELPING IN THE EFFORT TO FEND
OFF THE RUSSIANS, HE SAYS, AND
THAT HE TOO IS WILLING TO
SACRIFICE.
>> Translator: EVERYONE'S AFRAID
OF BEING KILLED.
IT'S ONE THING TO DIE WITH
HONOR.
ANOTHER THING IS TO DIE WITHOUT
>> Reporter: THE U.S. HAS SAID
UKRAINE'S AIR FORCE REMAINS
LARGEL